the number of downloads increased immediately after the
announcement of the conversation with the Russian
president. Details in the material by Anna
Voronina. The announcement of this interview has already
made so much noise that there is no doubt
left. The United States this evening, regardless
of political views and
moods, 18 o'clock in Washington will
watch Tucker Carlson's conversation with
Vladimir Putin, the excitement is incredible
It’s enough to look at the statistics of
the publication on the social network X, the former Twitter
video was watched 54 million times in 6 hours, and
this is not counting the audience who
watched the interview on the journalist’s website,
such interest can easily be explained by the
opportunity to find out the truth that
will break through the streams of lies and the
information Blockade in the West, they
will be very attentive  study this
interview, they will analyze it,
it is clear that there is a tendency to,
well, there is such a professional
professional, of course,
the reluctance to publish the interview was given to
Carlson because there is a split there, there is a
split in political views and the
corporate split in the media is very
serious,
they are very divided  strictly according to the criteria of
supporting one or another party of
one of the two, that’s why of course there is such a
certain jealousy professionally
Priest interview Well, Vladimir Vladimirovich, in
principle, answered honestly and openly,
therefore And to what extent the questions were
correct Well, I don’t know It’s not for me to judge,
of course, I think that you definitely need to
look this morning
I listened to some excerpts on the radio and decided that I
needed to see the entire opinion of the
first person of the state, especially on the
eve of the elections, it is very important for me. Well, to
hear the point of view in the West, I would
really like to hear it, but I
think that there will be
obstacles there. If he wants to, he will probably find an
interview and watch it  and
will draw its conclusions, but for the most part Unfortunately, I
hope I don’t hope that Russia won’t look.
As they say, it’s a great country, and in
this regard, it’s imperative to listen and find a
compromise point